all right welcome to Hannity we have a
lot breaking tonight the president just
excoriated the House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi right to her face in a
closed-door meeting at the White House
he called her a third-rate politician of
course the president's right her party's
deranged psychotic rage obsessive hate
Trump agenda is all that matters in her
world but the speaker's sloppy execution
well that leaves a lot to be desired
today we saw this all play out in real
time Pelosi and her colleagues or
attending a meeting surrounding the
administration's policy in Syria and
well they say a picture well speaks a
thousand words on Twitter well the
president called this nervous Nancy's
unhinged meltdown
looks like she's pointing at him at the
very same time that photo was taken the
House voted for a measures spearheaded
by Pelosi rebuking the president's
withdrawal of American troops from Syria
some Republicans even supported the
measure is what these lawmakers need to
keep in mind President Trump well he
promised to beat the living out of the
so called Isis Caliphate not so called
it was a caliphate he removed Obama's
insane ridiculous democratic rules of
engagement that put handcuffs on our
troops and guess what he bombed the
living daylights and beat back the
entire Caliphate in Syria of Isis that's
a promise he made and a promise he kept
and president Trump also promised to get
the United States out of all foreign
conflicts we can't have endless wars he
ran on this he got support for this in
Syria when weapons of mass destruction
were used
he didn't draw any meaningless line in
the sand like Obama no he actually acted
another promise made another promise
kept and look at this new poll a
majority of even Republicans do support
the president's decision to withdraw
troops America's wars are no longer
fought to be one instead eventually they
all get politicized right back here at
home dangerous restrictions are placed
on how our brave men and women our
national treasure our soldiers operate
and then disaster and Sue's Vietnam Iraq
Afghanistan you start the fight you
politicize the fight then we don't fight
anymore our national treasure dies they
lose their limbs they come home
disfigured and we even abandon them with
the VA scandal under the obama-biden
administration's now instead of
endlessly putting brave men and women in
harm's way the president well he is
sanctioning Turkey for their aggressive
action in the region it had a huge
impact on Iran and tonight Republicans
you need to keep something in mind here
Pelosi and her liberal friends they
don't care about what happens in the
Middle East at all and how do we know
that they are the ones that helped start
the wars and then when the going gets
tough they're the first people to
politicize them and put handcuffs on our
troops and ridiculous rules of
engagement during war we just supposed
to win it now we're supposed to believe
they're Hawks really on top of that we
also know this Democrats are only
reacting with rage because they are
completely preoccupied with just
smearing Trump bludgeoning Trump so
Pelosi's radical extreme socialist
supervisors in the Democratic Party the
squad they are demanding that this duly
elected President of the United States
be thrown out of office she wants to
keep her job she's doing what they say
and without a doubt the left hates Trump
more than anything they have now
convinced themselves he is Satan
incarnate and they'll do anything and
say anything to destroy the president
even act like they are really Hawks on
defense
just to RunAs agenda no matter what by
the way this is why we need the next
generation of weaponry so we don't do
this to America's treasure ever again I
want any future conflicts to be fought
in the air-conditioned offices in Tampa
where buttons are pushed and the enemy
dies offensive weapons and defensive
weapons so we don't have to send kids
door-to-door to get their legs blown up
again and not give them up armored
Humvees and then treat them like crap
when they come home with lifelong
injuries now president this president
cured cancer they would hold an
investigation into how he did it the
wrong way or would impeach him for the
for the issue of curing cancer this is
how sick ugly twisted it is now gotten
and it's a complete and total waste of
our time I remember breaking last night
Pelosi announced that there will be no
formal roll call on impeachment they
don't have the votes and that's because
there are enough Democrats in these
swing districts we keep scrolling the
names and they know that impeachment is
the end of their political careers come
2020 November by the way they also know
it's a manufactured scandal and they
know for them it's political suicide pay
close attention maybe that person is in
your district they don't want to go on
the record as an official anti-trump
conspiracy theorist and a district that
voted for Donald Trump and look at this
a brand new focus group featuring voters
from the great swing state of Ohio
showing just how unpopular this
impeachment hoax really is nine of
eleven participants raised their hands
to say impeachment is a distraction from
the issues they care the most about
so now Pelosi sloppy strategy is hitting
a speed bump her top deputy the cowardly
shifty Adam Schiff while he's holding
closed-door meeting secret meetings I
thought they wanted transparency didn't
they want the unredacted version of the
Muller report oh no due process for the
president whatsoever and by the way the
Cowardly shift expects us to believe
that an official impeachment proceeding
is underway by the way his House
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy pointed
out several basic constitutional rights
are being denied during this impeachment
sham the following questions have yet to
be answered and by the way all things
Newt Gingrich gave the Democrats when
the Republicans were in control the
house and real impeachment was going on
with Bill Clinton because the
independent counsel saw eleven felonies
and Bill Clinton's conduct and
identified them now speaker Pelosi do
you intend to grant co-equal subpoena
power to the chair and the ranking
member at the committee level do you
intend to require all subpoenas to be
subject to a vote of the full committee
at the request of either the chair or
the ranking member do you intend to
provide the president's counsel the
right to attend all hearings and all
depositions do you intend to provide the
president's counsel the right to present
evidence do you intend to provide the
president's counsel the
to object to the admittance of evidence
do you intend to provide the president's
counsel the right to recommend a witness
list and finally the intend to refer all
of this to Jerry Nadler
and his committees the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee that section
actually prescribed by the rules of the
house or is the Cowardly ship in charge
of leading this inquiry as has been
reported in the press every other
impeachment proceeding historically has
followed the simple basic fundamental
rules of fairness and justice
speaker Gingrich afforded those rights
to President Clinton and the Democratic
minority but today the speaker won't
even hold an official vote as
constitutional law professor Jonathan
Turley put a quote Pelosi seems to
believe that she can hold a press
conference and expect courts to accept
that a formal impeachment process has
begun while some judges are likely to be
uncomfortable with such a immaculate
impeachment very creative our own gregg
jarrett he called it a venomous affront
to constitutional principles and
breaking tonight one of those
closed-door hearings the secret kind but
the people that demand a transparency of
the Moller report will shift pressured a
key witness to lie look at this brand
new report from the Washington Examiner
one American diplomat Kurt Volker
repeatedly refused to agree with shifts
phony quid pro quo allegations Schiff
said quote ambassador you're making this
much more complicated than it has to be
I guess he wasn't getting the answer he
had hoped for and now get this the lying
cowardly shift well he doesn't even want
his fake whistleblower to testify now
he's rightfully likely concerned that
the non whistleblower whistleblower
would be forced to answer questions
about yeah their connection to shifts
office and the advice that they were
given by shifts office to get an
attorney and go to the inspector general
and by the way the non whistleblower
whistleblowers work for sleepy creepy
crazy uncle Joe Biden and how this was
essentially from the get-go a
democratic-led set up from the beginning
Wow we've read that book before too and
at least one prominent Democrat is now
calling for this non whistleblower
whistleblower to testify
looks like the radically
lefts attempt the latest scheme to boot
the president out of office yep
once again boomeranging coming apart at
the seams